So three weeks of jungle and ocean adventure take out its toll on your feet.
So in this eco fact, we're paying a visit to Dr. Fish.
Well, Dr. Fish isn't actually a real doctor, but definitely a fish,...
...well, in fact, two species,...
...both native to the Middle East that have made their way into society...
...because of their somewhat strange feeding preferences.
Hold on.
That's tickly.
These fish are members of the family Cyprinidae, which includes the minnows and the carps.
So this is a freshwater fish, and they've been called Dr. Fish...
...because they're extremely efficient in removing dead skin cells...
...and treating certain skin diseases such as psoriasis.
I don't think my feet have ever been this popular.